I want to give a shout out to Canada
this week because right we got Canadians
at yes I love Canada we all love Canada
and and you know I just want the people
up there to know cuz we've been on in
Canada for a while now and you know it's
not us you know that it's just the
president we love you and the contrast
between him and Justin Trudeau could not
be greater and I thought this is the
perfect time to do an update for
something I enjoyed for my entire
childhood
well goof with some gallant you remember
school Chrissy Galant goofus and gallant
you know those kind of cartoons they
used to have you know goofus I can't
read that but it's way that looks like
the eye chart doesn't it just a good
thing and Go Fish anything and we
thought the young dashing polite Justin
Trudeau it's such a great contrast to
the old fat stupid Donald Trump
so we're updating goofus and gallant to
the Justin and Donnell for example
Justin waits politely for women to get
on an elevator first Donald grabs their
Juston research is an issue and consults
experts before reaching a decision
Donald vomits brain farts and leaves his
staff to clean up the mess
justin speaks the king's english donald
speaks queen's douche bag
Juston remains devoted to his wife whom
he met in high school
Donald remains devoted to Kim jong-un
who he met three days ago
Juston separates paper and glass donald
separates parents and children
Justin took an oath to protect his
nation Donald doesn't wear protection
[Applause]
Justin eats with a fork and knife will
find China Donald each with his heads
out of a bucket Justin tells his staff
you have a problem happy no Donald tells
he'll snap leave me alone I'm pooped
tweeting Justin knows the importance of
balancing work and family
Donald is pretty sure of the name of one
of his daughter starts with a team
Justin looks sexy with his hair blowing
in the breeze subtle looks like mr.
clean stapled to dead fairies
justin has a passion to box
Donald's wife arrived in a box